I have to bring up what I told you
yesterday but our boy Ben has found some
of the funniest porn like just titles
cuz you know like were they real no yeah
they really he was he actually finding
these tools like you can look he's he's
watching porn
finding the like just seeing these in
the in the sidebar and then sending them
to you not as he's going I would hope so
he finishes up yeah he finishes up and
then saves it and then at a later time
he goes hey while I had my takeout I
found this piece of medium right he's
like I don't you know though it's not
out right now yeah it was but not now
but not we can laugh over these together
now
and I know that like captain captain's
milk has been distributed
I think porn is a hit like the nastiest
it could go I think I think there's like
I think porn can't get any grosser than
it is now right like they have
everything like everything right but now
we're getting in I feel like it's been
this way you've heard of foreign titles
like this before
but the fact that these weird like
psychological scenarios or like the hot
thing I think proves like we're beyond
the point of costumes and pain and you
know like the like the physical
intensity right like I see what you're
saying yeah now it's like you know feed
that inner Oedipus complex mm-hmm get
that Edda [ __ ] yeah so the first one is
your bully's hot mom grinds your dick
[Laughter]
damn that's dope actually right that's a
good one
if I [ __ ] my bully's mom that's great
why didn't this beak widen this hat like
come before the physical stuff right you
would think it would start here and then
go to like you know gaping right that to
me is more natural progression gaping
missile inside cuban latina yeah you
know aka the Cuban Missile Crisis
alright there's a body swap accident
okay now it's getting
now it's getting crazy are we talking
like Freaky Friday stuff yeah body
swathi SWAT make accident come in her
mouth which I don't understand I don't
know what I don't get that one at all so
whose body did you swap into oh maybe
you swapped into the dude that was
[ __ ] her and then oh she didn't want
to come in their mouth and you came in
her mouth okay because you were a
different guy only become your dad and
now
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm all set on that one thank you very
much that's give me one second just yeah
just good yeah all right what's the
third one
my stepsons orgasmic touch never tell
you I went down this long long AMA read
it of like anyone that's ever actually
done incest like what was it like and
all the stories were [ __ ] like
catastrophic none of them were like okay
that's cool you know like because people
always say like oh if it was the second
cousin it was a sudden what so then why
is it such like a fetish I don't know
but all the stories I remember that AMA
were like yeah I banged my second cousin
and now all of our family members cut us
off and we don't talk to each other
anymore and I had to change my name and
like this is like really dark heavy [ __ ]
and you're like well is there anyone is
there anyone like actually [ __ ] their
stepmom no everything I had read was
like weird like family reunion stuff
like okay know that and that's why they
thought they could get away with it
because it's like oh so like actually
related [ __ ] by actual incest yeah
I don't know man I don't know what you
practice I don't know man I would never
[ __ ] a sibling or I would have never do
incest honestly honestly I know that's
kind of a weird opinion but yeah I don't
think I would ever do it I don't know
about you man but I just don't know if I
could ever really [ __ ] my brother yeah
I'm not really into you know family
[ __ ]
we know we should do it like morning
hosts and I know and I can tell you this
Cody I can say this with absolute
confidence mm-hmm I personally would
never okay never have sex with my
sibling oh oh
no I'll agreed I'm with you 100%
yeah I would never ever [ __ ] a family
member
personally and you know that that's a if
a family member sorry sorry radio buddy
no potty mouth today I woke up on a
weird side of the bed not but not
sister's bed right of course not no I
would never freak her all right coming
up next we have the Blues Brothers and
some Backstreet Boys all right the last
one and this is the best one I can't
take it anymore I [ __ ] my stepsister
asked during confinement confinement oh
we got Kody with that one confinement I
can't take it any yeah I can't take it
anymore I can't take it anymore I have
to [ __ ] her ass NUCCA means that could
mean anything dude that could mean like
they already were [ __ ] I know but now
he like he just wanted to [ __ ]
and he can't take it anymore I need to
[ __ ] her eyes--and confinement someone
can feign confinement like with an A
yeah so you know I intended to bring his
own containment oh you're right I
couldn't harass in confinement I have to
[ __ ] her eyes--and convenient for [ __ ]
see sight all beautiful crocheted all in
confinement I have to [ __ ] her and I
tell you what Here I am I've got a
[ __ ] confinement M
you